[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
les pays européens doivent rappeler
leurs ambassadeurs
la situation en Iran depuis
l'arrestation et la mort de Massa Amini
le 16 septembre 2022 pour un voile mal
porté appelle une condamnation claire et
nette de la répression exercée contre
les manifestants de nombreux élus
partout dans le monde ont dénoncé cette
situation et appeler leur gouvernement à
réagir
indifférent en protestation de la
communauté internationale le régime
iranien continue néanmoins emprisonner
et à exécuter ses opposants pour
terroriser la population et tenter
d'étouffer la contestation dans une
telle situation la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense du
Sénat estime que l'indispensable
dénonciation de cette brutalité
révoltante ne suffit plus il faut des
actes
la France et ses partenaires doivent à
la fois dénoncer et contrecarrer
l'oppression d'un peuple par des
dirigeants qui ne se maintiennent que
par la violence et la terreur dans un
communiqué de presse diffuser le 9
janvier 2023 la Commission demande ainsi
publiquement au gouvernement de proposer
au 27 pays de l'Union européenne de
rappeler pour consultation leurs
ambassadeurs en Iran le président de la
commission Christian Cambon avait
formulé cette demande dès le 19 décembre
dans un courrier adressé à Catherine
Colonna ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères
porteur de valeur de liberté et de
tolérance les pays européens doivent
présenter un front unif face aux
déchaînement de violence du régime
iranien le temps des messages feutrés et
des sanctions tièdes est révolu
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]